♪
>> THANKS TO OUR MILITARY AND
OUR ALLIES AND THE BRAVE
FIGHTERS OF AFGHANISTAN, THE
TALIBAN REGIME IS COMING TO AN
END.
>> BY THE END OF THIS YEAR, THE
TRANSITION WILL BE COMPLETE AND
AFGHANS WILL TAKE FULL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THEIR
SECURITY AND OUR COMBAT MISSION
WILL BE OVER.
>> WHAT ARE WE GOING TO SAY WE
WILL STAY FOR ANOTHER 21 YEARS
AND ANOTHER 50.
THE WHOLE THING IS RIDICULOUS.
WE ARE BRINGING THE TROOPS BACK
HOME FROM AFGHANISTAN.
>> TALIBAN TAKEOVER OF
AFGHANISTAN NOW INEVITABLE?
>> NO, IT IS NOT.
>> Bret: BUT IT IS HAPPENING.
THE TALIBAN IS TAKING CONTROL OF
AFGHANISTAN.
CURRENTLY AS OF TODAY, 240
DISTRICTS THE TALIBAN CONTROLS.
AND THERE IS SOME CONTESTED
AREAS FALLEN, HER ROTH, GAZA
ANYTHING, ALL HAVE FALLEN, NOW
THE U.S. IS PUTTING MORE TROOPS
IN MARINES AND OTHER TROOPS TO
BE ABLE TO GET AMERICANS OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN.
FOUR DIFFERENT PRESIDENTS,
ALMOST 20 YEARS AND NOW THIS IS
HOW THIS IS COMING TO AN END IN
AFGHANISTAN.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL BEN
DOMENECH PUBLISHER OF THE
FEDERALIST.
MARA LIASSON NATIONAL POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT "THE WASHINGTON
POST" COLUMNIST MARC THIESSEN.
MARK, YOU WROTE SOME SPEECHES AT
THE BEGINNING OF THAT -- THE
WAR.
AND THROUGHOUT.
IT IS JUST TALKING TO GENERAL
KEANE AND OTHERS, IT IS TOUGH TO
WATCH.
>> IT IS TOUGH TO WATCH.
AND YOU AND I TRAVELED TOGETHER
TO DO A BUNCH OF THOSE CITIES
YOU JUST NAMED WHEN YOU WERE A
PENTAGON CORRESPONDENT AND I WAS
WORKING IN THE PENTAGON FOR
SECRETARY RUMSFELD.
IT'S HEART-BREAKING TO SEE
WHAT'S UNFOLDING OVER THERE BUT,
IF YOU WANT TO UNDERSTAND JUST
HOW PATHETIC THIS
ADMINISTRATION'S AFGHAN POLICY
IS.
HERE IS THE LEAD OF A STORY
THAT'S ON THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
WEBSITE RIGHT NOW.
JUST WENT UP A COUPLE HOURS AGO.
AMERICAN NEGOTIATORS ARE TRYING
TO EXTRACT ASSURANCES FROM THE
TALIBAN THAT THEY WILL NOT
ATTACK THE U.S. EMBASSY IN KABUL
IF THE EXTREMIST GROUP TAKES
OVER THE COUNTRY'S GOVERNMENT
AND EVER WANTS TO RECEIVE U.S.
FOREIGN AIDE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
DANGLING U.S. FOREIGN AID TO THE
PEOPLE WHO AIDED AND ABETTED THE
ATTACKS OF SEPTEMBER 11TH, 2011
IF THEY PLEASE DON'T ATTACK THE
U.S. EMBASSY.
THAT IS PROBABLY IN THE MOST
ENTIRE CAREER IN WASHINGTON THE
MOST PATHETIC THING I EVER EVER
SEEN.
EXPRESSION OF WEAKNESS I HAVE
EVER SEEN WHEN IT COMES TO U.S.
FOREIGN POLICY.
>> Bret: TO THAT POINT THE
MESSAGING CHANGED OVER THE LAST
24 HOURS.
JOHN KIRBY PENTAGON SPOKESPERSON
ON LAST NIGHT HE WAS SAYING THAT
PART OF THE GIVE AND TAKE IS TO
HAVE THE TALIBAN UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY RISK BEING A PARIAH IN THE
WORLD.
HERE'S THAT EXCHANGE.
>> THE TALIBAN CONTINUES TO
TRIED TO A ADVANCE IN THE
COUNTRY THROUGH BRUTALITY,
THROUGH OPPRESSION, THROUGH
FEAR.
THOSE KIND OF TACTICS ARE NOT
GOING TO LEAD TO THE LEVEL OF
LEGITIMACY THAT THEY SAY THEY
WANT FROM THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY.
THAT'S.
>> Bret: ADMIRAL, DO YOU THINK
THE TALIBAN IS GOING TO SAY WE
WANT TO BE LEGITIMATE IN THE
WORLD'S EYES?
THAT THAT'S GOING TO BE THE
THREAT THAT MAKES THEM STOP
BEHEADING OR EXECUTING PEOPLE.
>> BRET, THEY HAVE SAID
THEMSELVES THEY WANT LEGITIMACY
AND WANT TO HAVE A HAND IN
GOVERNANCE WHICH MEANS THEY HAVE
TO COME TO THE TABLE AND BE PART
OF THE NEGOTIATED POLITICAL
SETTLEMENT.
>> Bret: CLEARLY, MARK, THAT'S
NOT HAPPENING AND NOW U.S.
TROOPS ARE GOING.
IN AND THAT'S A DANGER IN AND OF
ITSELF.
>> IT'S A DANGER IN AND OF
THEY ARE GOING IN TO GET
AMERICANS OUT SAFELY.
BUT THIS IS A TRAGEDY FROM TOP
TO BOTTOM.
EVERY WAY YOU LOOK AT THIS.
I MEAN, WE WERE IN AFGHANISTAN
FOR 20 YEARS.
THE PURPOSE ORIGINALLY WAS TO
DENY AL QAEDA A SAFE HAVEN TO
LAUNCH TERRORIST ATTACKS AGAINST
THE UNITED STATES.
IT SEEMS LIKE WE HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED THAT WE HAVEN'T HAD
ANY ATTACKS FROM THERE.
BUT, AFTER 20 YEARS OF POURING
RESOURCES AND TRAINING INTO
AFGHANISTAN, THEIR OWN SECURITY
FORCES ARE STILL NOT ABLE TO
DEFEND THEIR OWN TERRITORY.
YOU'VE HAD CONSECUTIVE
ADMINISTRATIONS.
YOU JUST PLAYED ALL THOSE
SOUNDBITES.
TWO AMERICAN PRESIDENTS WANTED
OUT.
TWO AMERICAN ADMINISTRATIONS
DECIDED THAT HAVING AMERICAN
TROOPS IN AFGHANISTAN WAS NOT IN
THE NATIONAL SECURITY INTEREST
OF THE UNITED STATES, AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE, FIRST OF
ALL, TIRED OF IT THEY DON'T WANT
AMERICAN TROOPS THERE THEY ALSO
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE
DOING THERE.
>> Bret: YEAH.
JUST IN THE LAST FEW MINUTES WE
GOT WORD THAT SECRETARY BLINKEN
AND SECRETARY AUSTIN STATE AND
DEFENSE SECRETARIES HAD A CALL
WITH THE AFGHAN PRESIDENT ASHRAF
GHANI.
THEY ARE SAYING THAT THEY ARE
COMMITTED TO THE STABILITY AND
SECURITY OF AFGHANISTAN, BEN,
BUT THEY ARE ALSO PRIVATELY
SHOOTING DOWN STORIES OF RUMORS
THAT THEY ASKED BEGANY TO
RESIGN.
THOUGHTS ABOUT THIS AS IT'S
EVOLVING JUST OVER THE PAST
COUPLE DAYS.
>> YOU KNOW, I'M A CHILD OF THE
80'S, BRET.
AND MY SIBLINGS AND MY BROTHERS
IN LAW HAVE SPENT FAR MORE TIME
IN AFGHANISTAN THAN ANYONE ON
THIS PANEL.
AND I WAS TALKING TO MY BROTHER
RIGHT BEFORE I CAME ON, AND I
SAID WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO
SAY?
AND HE SAID WHAT DO YOU EXPECT?
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT AFTER ALL OF
THIS?
OKAY, A POLICY THAT WAS
MISBEGOTTEN IN TERMS OF THE
ANTICIPATION OF TRYING TO
ACHIEVE THINGS IN AFGHANISTAN
THAT MAY BE UNACHIEVABLE.
BLOOD THAT CRIES OUT FROM THE
BLOOD THERE, I THINK, IN TERMS
OF WASTED RESOURCES AND LIVES
WHEN IT CAME TO AMERICAN POLICY.
AND I THINK A FAILED DEFINITION
OF VICTORY IN SO MANY DIFFERENT
RESPECTS AND ACROSS MULTIPLE AND
BIPARTISAN ADMINISTRATIONS.
WE HAVE HAD THREE PRESIDENTS IN
A ROW ELECTED BASED ON ARGUING
AGAINST THE WARS IN THE MIDDLE
EAST AND IN AFGHANISTAN.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THE NEO
CONSERVATIVE AGENDA THAT CARES
SO MUCH ABOUT DEMOCRACY OVERSEAS
IS NOT VERY INTERESTED IN
LISTENING TO IT HERE AT HOME.
AND I THINK, INSTEAD, WHAT WE
OUGHT TO BE ASKING IS IF THIS
WAS SOMETHING THAT WE WANTED TO
ACHIEVE WHERE WE HAD A CLEAR
GOAL, HOW COULD IT HAVE BEEN
ARGUED BETTER?
HOW COULD IT HAVE BEEN MANAGED
BETTER?
HOW COULD HAVE THE POLICIES
ACTUALLY LINED UP WITH WHAT WE
WANTED TO ACHIEVE AS OPPOSED TO
THIS EMBARRASSING END?
>> Bret: MARA, I WANT TO GIVE
YOU THE LAST WORD.
THIS IS REALLY PAINFUL FOR A LOT
OF PEOPLE RIGHT NOW.
GOLD STAR FAMILIES, VETERANS,
FAMILIES WHO HAVE ALL ENDURED
SACRIFICE THERE, AND THEY SAY A
LOT OF HEARTS ARE HEAVY RIGHT
NOW.
THEIR PHONES ARE FLOODED WITH
VETERANS WHO ARE REALLY
STRUGGLING WITH INFORMATION
ABOUT AFGHANISTAN.
AND TRYING TO COME TO GRIPS WITH
IT AND WE ARE GOING TO PUT UP ON
THE SCREEN THE VETERANS CRISIS
HOTLINE ON THE BOTTOM OF THE
SCREEN IF YOU WANT TO TALK TO
SOMEBODY THROUGH THIS.
MARK, LAST WORD, QUICKLY?
>> WE ARE SEEING HISTORY REPEAT
ITSELF.
JOE BIDEN PRESIDED OVER
DISASTROUS WITHDRAWAL OF IRAQ
LED TO ISIS.
TERRORIST NETWORK THAT SPREAD
ITS TENTACLES AND CARRIED OUT
ATTACKS IN 29 COUNTRIES AND
KILLED MORE THAN 2,000 PEOPLE
AROUND THE WORLD.
KHALID SHEIKH MOHAMMED PREDICTED
THIS.
HE TOLD HIS CIA NEGOTIATOR AND
INTERROGATOR IN HIS CELL IN A
BLACK SITE WE WILL WIN BECAUSE
AMERICANS DON'T REALIZE WE DON'T
NEED TO DEFEAT YOU MILITARILY WE
ONLY NEED TO FIGHT LONG ENOUGH
TO LOSE B